Here are two cells on your screen.
Can you tell me which one is a plant cell
and which is an animal cell by merely glancing at them ?
Don’t worry !
It’s not that difficult !
Plant and animal cells can be distinguished
from each other by merely looking at them.
The presence and absence of a few characters
are enough to let us know the differences.
Let us go through the differences one by one.
If we travel from outside of the cell to the inner core,
then the first difference we find
is the presence and absence of cell wall.
Plant cells have a proper, well-defined cell wall.
On the other hand,
animal cells do not have a cell wall at all !
They just have the cell membrane
which is also a part of the plant cell !
It is due to the cell wall
that the plant cells obtain this proper defined shape.
On the other hand, animal cells
do not have a proper shape because they lack cell wall.
The next obvious difference
is the presence of chloroplast in the plant cell.
This, as we have already studied,
is the exclusive organelle for plant cell.
It is absent in animal cells.
Can you now help me with the third difference ?
That’s right !
The presence of vacuoles.
Both plant and animal cells contain vacuoles.
However, in plant cells,
the vacuole is a large one located at the center.
While in animal cells,
there are numerous small sized vacuoles.
The central vacuole can occupy majority of the
cell space pushing other organelles to the periphery.
The case of animal cells is slightly different.
Here, the vacuoles are much smaller in size
and they are scattered throughout the cytoplasm.
Apart from these,
there are several other differences in these two cells.
But we will have a look at them in our higher grades.
For now, you tell me,
is classification of cells done only on these basis ?
Are there only two types of cells ?
Plant cells and animal cells ?
Think for a moment !
The answer is a definite no !
This was just the difference between plant and
animal cells.
This is not the way cells are classified.
Then how do we classify the cells ?
Cells are broadly classified in two major types.
Prokaryotic cells and Eukaryotic cells !
Here are the two types we are referring to !
This is a typical prokaryotic cell
and this is a eukaryotic cell.
Let us begin understanding the
difference between the two !
To begin with,
the name prokaryotic helps us know its structure.
The term “Pro” indicates primitive
and the term “karyon” refers to a kernel
which means “nucleus” in this case.
So do these cells have a primitive type of nucleus ?
Well, these cells do not actually have a
proper well-defined nucleus.
Can you see these thread like structures scattered
in the cytoplasm ?
This is nothing but the genetic material named nucleoid.
The nucleoid is analogous to the nucleus in our cells.
It has strands of DNA, RNA
and it carries the genetic information of the cell.
The only difference is that the nucleoid does not have a
compact shape and mainly lacks a proper membrane.
The next obvious difference is that the organelles
are also not membrane bound.
That means the prokaryotic cell does not have
well defined membranes for the different organelles.
On the other hand, the eukaryotic cell,
which means cell with a true nucleus has well defined,
membranes for nucleus as well as the other organelles.
There are several other features
but we will not get into their details for now.
Tell me one thing…
Doesn’t this look like an animal cell ?
Yes it does !
That is because this IS an animal cell !
So is animal cell an example of eukaryotic cell ?
Yes it is !
Both plant and animal cells
can be included in the category of eukaryotic cells.
So which cells will be in the prokaryotic type ?
Cells of lower organisms
like various bacteria have prokaryotic cells !